foreign
[Music]
are we seeing double here Northwest is
the spitting image of her dad Kanye and
her latest Tick Tock yes the
nine-year-old who loves experimenting
with special effects makeup put her
creative skills to the test and the
outcome is uncanny especially with Mom
Kim Kardashian by her side but that's
not all another Tick Tock from the
mother daughter Duo also had fans
talking due to its interesting song
choice
[Music]
now this video of course had fans
wondering if Kim was referring to
Kanye's long-standing Feud with Taylor
Swift which infamously started over a
decade ago at the VMAs now with the
couple's divorce finalized this past
November Kim emotionally spoke out about
co-parenting with Kanye during a recent
appearance on the Angie Martinez IRL
podcast amid Kanye's harmful
anti-semitic comments and other
controversies here's what Kim had to say
I
definitely protected him and I still
will in
the eyes of my kids for my kids so in my
home my kids don't know anything that
goes on on the outside world I'm Holding
On by a thread I know I'm like so close
to that not happening but while it's
still that way I will protect that
to the end of the Earth as long as I can
like for parenting it's really [ __ ]
hard you know and like
you're not co-parenting with the
with just anyone yeah for the quiet but
I had the best dad and I had the best
memories and the greatest experience and
that's all I want for my kids as long as
they can have that that's what I would
want for them you know so like
if they don't know things that are being
said
or what's happening in the world like
why would I ever bring that energy to
them